hey 42 here from stealing candy to
drinking your dad's booze or
accidentally buying the Daily Mail we've
all done things were not proud of for
many of us if we do something bad it's
just a matter of running away or
deleting our browser history
no Bing nobody notices but throughout
human history many people have lived the
idea that someone somewhere is keeping a
score and when we finally do kick the
bucket
we'll have to account for all the bad
things that we've done hell it
immediately conjures up images of flame
filled caves and red horned demons
prodding people with forks but is this
what every religion thinks of or is it
just part of the judeo-christian
traditions so what do other religions
believe today we look at six different
versions of help from around the world
or on the world now that if you lived
most of your life on a frozen land
crossing the seas under an Arctic breeze
and somebody told you that there was a
way to spend eternity in a fiery pit
that he'd probably think it was quite a
good idea Norse mythology had nine
worlds all connected by the cosmic ash
tree the idris hill one of the Worlds
was nivel hey the hell of the Norse a
place of freezing cold darkness it was
overseen by Loki's daughter named hel
who also conveniently ran Helheim which
was just for regular dead people not
really bad people or the great warriors
who have died in battle
just old regular folk that weren't
particularly liked very much it mainly
consisted of estate agents and
politicians Helheim was watched over by
a massive
eagle called corpse eater one of the
other world's moose bill Heim consisted
of fire and volcanoes and was ruled by
fire Giants at the other end of the
spectrum was another of the nine worlds
Asgard the home of the gods
ruled by Odin inside Asgard Lies
Valhalla where brave warriors would go
to if they died in battle
Zoroastrianism is one of the oldest
religions in the world and still has a
few hundred thousand beliefs
us in India and a run as well as some
other religious hipsters you know the
combination of cosmic donek dualism and
eschatological monotheism is super retro
you just wouldn't get it their Supreme
Being is a who a Mazda which isn't a
Japanese sports car and Zoroastrianism
has a really unique afterlife belief
once you die you must cross the beam
shaped bridge that splits the world of
living and the dead but your Crossing is
dependent on your behavior if you are a
good person then you got a nice wide
bridge and you were met by a beautiful
spirit called Dana who led you off to
the house of song which sounds like a
karaoke bar and my personal idea of hell
but hint to the row however if you were
a naughty person then the bridge would
be razor fin and the demon vis arrest
would push you off and you'd fall into
the House of Lies a filthy place where
you'd always be alone permanently
tortured and fed awful spoiled food so
basically an NHS hospital
the ancient Greeks loved a good bit of
mythology and their gods were like the
cast of a psychotic horny soap opera
Hades famously ran the regular
underworld but far beneath it as deep as
the heavens were high was the black pit
called Tartarus it was created out of
chaos at the same time as the heavens
and the earth and was mainly used to
house things that the gods wanted out of
the way like murderous creatures and
Adam Sandler movies but it was also used
to punish people who have really booked
the guns and rather than a generic
off-the-shelf
punishment for everybody there is a
unique punishment for each sinner
Sisyphus had to keep rolling a boulder
or per hill for eternity
Tantalus was always hungry and thirsty
and Xen had to spin around on a flaming
wheel which actually sounds quite fun
for a while anyway
Tartarus was also used to imprison many
of the Titans after they tried to
overthrow the gods
each Titan was guarded by one of the
Heckert on curries Giants with 50 heads
in the hundred arms some stories say how
the Titan
were burnt and mankind was actually
created out of there fatty smoke a bit
like how Eve was created from Adam's
ribs so the moral of this story is that
whatever your religion is we were all
created from some kind of barbecue much
like how the Vikings gods reflected
their surroundings the mythology of
Samoa is as you'd expect from a remote
island very ocean based for example a
God of wallet in Ola failed Oh leafy the
house of the octopus since he was a
giant octopus the entrance to the
underworld was found at fafa and dead
spirits would have to swim west along
the cluster of islands until they
reached the furthest points on Upolu
and threw themselves from the leaping
stone to swim on out into the afterworld
fafa housed two entrances pilato led to
the Blessed lands and salafi was the
land of the bound it was guarded by a
giant called Mosu who apparently jumped
from Samoa to Fiji which is quite
impressive and may Mosu eat you is still
used as an insult to this day next we
head to Mongolia the country has a long
history of shamanism including special
objects and animals and sacrificial
altars called a ruse in Mongolian
shamanism dead souls are judged by air
kill car the Prince of the underworld he
does some quick mental arithmetic and
counts up all like good deeds versus
their bad ones
if the maths goes against them as mass
tends to do then they are hurled into
CAHSEE ago a giant cauldron full of
bubbling tar but all is not lost the
less that they've sinned the quicker
that they rise to the top of the culture
and the quicker they can go free to take
a shower for a few hundred years as that
tar must be bloody difficult to get off
what's more you're not in it entirely on
your own since anyone in heaven who
benefited from one of your good deeds
during your life can send of spirit to
drag you up slightly quicker by grabbing
onto your hair just don't die bald
that's what I'm taking from this be good
and don't be bald die in a wig if you
must finally we come to the most
children
Rastafarians 'm it was founded in 1930
when Haile Selassie became Emperor of
Ethiopia Rastafarians and Fink's of
Ethiopia as Zion which is the birthplace
of mankind and so is also heaven on
earth you can enter the Holy Land by
literal geographical travel or in a
spiritual way making the emotional
journey before your lazy body actually
does get back because your body may have
slight motivational issues given the
enormous mountain of weed you just gone
through so then that's heaven what about
Hell well hell was actually Jamaica this
is because many Africans ended up in
Jamaica due to the slave trade so
understandably it had a lot of negative
connotations whether it's freezing caves
pushing giant rocks up of hills or just
good old fire and brimstone at one point
we've all wished that whoever just stole
our parking space should end up their
eternal punishment may seem ridiculous
to syllables or very plausible two of us
I guess it really depends on how many
times you've had to watch frozen with
your kids thanks for the view subscribe
for more 42
pretty much every shop restaurant and
bar in the world uses a system of secret
codes but in reality how real is the
American president's power how much
power do they really possess